boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sakyan we
are in New York City New York we are
going to be talking about all things
conversational user interfaces we're
going to be talking about intelligent
agents and artificial intelligence
saving time and I'm really excited to
have Dennis Mortensen joining us on the
show hello thanks so much for having me
I'm super pumped this is going to be
it's gonna be good it's gonna be a
really exciting episode
um a quick background on Dennis Dennis
is from Denmark and he's never giving up
his accent that's true sticking to it
sticking to it I love it uh he's been
five years now as the CEO and founder of
x dot AI really excited to break that
down for you guys in a bit previously
four years as the CEO and founder of
visual Revenue which was predictive
analysis for media and that was acquired
in previous previous to that six years
as a CEO and shareholder of index tools
which did Enterprise web analytics and
that was acquired by Yahoo in May 2008
he's also the author of data driven
insights which is about collecting and
analyzing Digital Data so all about data
all about AI all about making life
better for humans I'm really excited
let's jump in from a big history
perspective on things so
we find ourselves after so many years as
stewards these Human animals are now
stewards of Earth and we're at this
hockey stick of exponential technology
we're at the hockey stick of population
explosion so what do you what are your
thoughts on this current state
I think it's
super easy to be pessimistic
and there's plenty of things which you
can let's onto that would suggest that
tomorrow won't really be better than
yesterday and you can even kind of
fall asleep thinking perhaps my kids
will be okay but thereafter I can barely
see how this is gonna play out why
because it doesn't require any energy
it does require some energy and some
willingness to dream up what might be
next why will we be better off what are
the things that we don't have today that
could come along and that will have to
kind of not be lazy they'll force you to
read things for where sure that could
have also happen and I'm just in the
category of where I'm much rather invest
some time and energy try to dream up
if for nothing else just for me and my
kids some version of the future where
we're going to be way better off and
that's what I let John do doesn't mean
that I'm not reading the paper not
seeing the signs there's plenty of
science but perhaps those are just
signals to then go work on it you do
your startup clean whatever Lake clean
whatever pocket of air over there do
whatever you think you can do to make
tomorrow a little bit better but that's
uh that's what I'm latching on to
yes very very optimistic and very
important I like to dose up on the on
the realism which is the optimism and
also the importance of mitigating the
existential risks ahead of us we had
very close calls in the cold war with
mutually assured destruction I think
we're going to have some close calls
again potentially with artificial
general intelligences and so it's
crucial for us to evolve as humans that
you you gave this really beautiful
optimistic view of that if we can just
really latch onto the essence of unity
and of being together here on this
planet we can make sure that our kids
and their kids as kids can unleash their
full creativity into solving these
problems and
plenty of the data we see in aggregate
certainly on human emotion if you will
it's an aggregate that tilts towards a
generation that's seeing dramatic change
however if you do segment out the most
optimistic part of that population that
tends to be young people actually those
who got the most to lose
why is it that those who got the most to
lose
are the most optimistic that should be
almost reversed where if you're 65 you
could kind of give a damn write this one
out and say world it's going to come to
an end I had fun while here and that's
that no the very people for where you
got another 70 years kind of sees a
version which is exciting
that should be encouraging forget about
what you and I think somehow they see
something and they're 13 years old
I'm not giving up you can keep pushing
me but I'm I won't give up on this fact
that human Ingenuity up until this point
have gotten it out of plenty of
interesting settings to put it polite in
the past and why is it at this one time
or this particular moment is one for
where we just couldn't figure it out
yeah I don't buy into it yeah
and there's plenty of reasons for why
anybody who will be watching this will
immediately say damn Dennis is naive
perhaps but there's suddenly plenty of
people who are naive about whatever
Venture they're working on or whatever
problem they're working on but I think
it's the fact that they are naive they
kind of allows them to say yeah I'll
lean into this for years on end because
I can see a better outcome
yeah now okay time is the most valuable
commodity that we have and this is what
we we want to eliminate drudgery from
our lives we don't want to go back and
forth 10 000 times in communication with
people to try and schedule meetings we
don't want to have to take extra time
like you you have this really good uh
story that you paint out of you'll land
in your in your hotel in this in this in
the next city that you're traveling to
and and instead of instead of having to
go on your phone and try and locate
somewhere to you know get your your your
um your drink that you would like
instead you just say Alexa order me a
flavored water or whatever and then boom
just like that it arrives at your door
five minutes later that eliminates 10
steps of drudgery of trying to look
things up on your phone trying to maybe
pick up a phone and call someone and
whatever deal with delivery the robot
will come and deliver you the flavored
water so tell us about the importance of
saving time and how these intelligent
agents can do this for us
again uh in my uh naive optimistic view
of the future which uh I really want
everybody to be part of this is not just
for me this is not for the select few I
think this is for everybody so we've had
this
long-lasting promise of us having to
work less
Keane suggested at some point we'll be
working 10-15 hours and I think we are
now so far into that uh promise that we
can barely see when and or if that's
gonna happen but I think at this moment
we might actually finally have reached
some inflection point in technology for
some of the very chores that comes along
with pretty much any job
could disappear now then we're going to
talk about
how much less we will end up working
because of that but I think there's
certainly a step one for where you can
be an account manager in customer
success in sales an engineer a recruiter
doesn't matter if you go look at
that certain bullets which they hired
you on hey I would like you to be our
recruiter over at Spotify hear the seven
things that you're going to be
responsible for now go and look at your
inbox how many of those emails over the
last two days can you latch on to those
seven bullets
half if half that means half your life
is you just have to deal with to do
the fun part where you find it exciting
to be in a recruiter over at Spotify but
they're right over here by the way and
in that regard I think that 50 is about
to disappear those are those little
Annoying chores that are not hard or
difficult or require true human
Ingenuity it just requires you to do it
you want to be reimbursed for that bagel
you got to do those five little tasks if
you want to meet up with me next
Wednesday at one we have to do a little
bit of ping pong and that is just those
parts that comes along with every job
that I think in phase one will disappear
now when they disappear
there's the idea again if you're lazy
that ah okay that means then there'll be
a pool of people who lose their job
because instead of having two people I
can have one person
that suggests
you either assume
we couldn't come up with other things we
want those people to do or that the very
same recruiter just made sure that we
ended up with better candidates spoke to
more candidates any number of a hundred
thousand other things that you can
imagine not just less people less people
it's just such an easy thing to say
because you don't have to think about
what are the 40 things that could happen
now for the recruiter so again I think
that is phase one that is about less
chores perhaps the same amount of time
spent at the office now this next phase
what I would like to see and surprise
I'm going all in so there's certainly
some setting right for where my dad
would take on a job and pretty much stay
in the same location do that job for
decades at a time and that's kind of how
work or jobs worked at that moment in
time and I think on that Vector we've
reached this point for where
people in your generation will change
jobs every two three years and it will
be normal not this loyal just normal and
it's also become normal for where you
might not even need to come into the
office the whole idea of the fully
distributed team is not exotic that is
becoming the norm not yet fully in the
norm
but if that is a vector what is the most
extreme version of that
because it looks like we are working
less and less time for the same company
we're coming less and less often into
the office
so perhaps the future and this is going
to sound crazy it's really just
wonderful where you and me are more like
a professional footballers We join the
club we play some good games we're
playing multiple tournaments at the same
time I might join another club and it's
all going to be extremely flexible on
our end and I think we might start to uh
not want to separate work
and life into these two buckets for
where we've been told
for years and end if you can't separate
those two you might not be in a healthy
position
perhaps
we should blend them so well so when I
ask you you just talk about a life well
lived that's right
that's right sorry let's head into a
million rant there I love the optimistic
rant I love that I'm I'm a big fan of
what you just said and I think that
Richard Branson has also made it very
clear that there is no such thing as a
work-life balance you gotta love what
you do you'd be so obsessed with what
you do that that you breathe eat sleep
love it every moment it's part of your
essence and so you talk about blending
that line you also talk about how these
kind of come in these next I like I like
the footballer analogy that's a good one
when you are
going from a big part of Futures gig
economy so as you go and you work for a
couple years couple matches a couple
tournaments at a certain workplace and
then you go and move on to another one
and help them out for a couple
tournaments maybe win a championship
with them Etc that's a good analogy I
like that a lot that's a huge part of
our future because your creativity can
be used in different in different um
tournaments and so that's your job is to
go into those different places use your
creativity and then swap let other
people have their creative shots
um there's a bunch of effort in wanting
to decrease the time vortexes like you
were describing there's the calendar uh
there's the email time Vortex the
texting time Vortex the social media
time Vortex and so we do things like you
and I were just talking beforehand about
how we both always have our
notifications off in our on our voice on
silent the the noise a phone noise ring
around silent and that itself frees us
up to be able to creatively do what we
want and when we need to use the device
we access the device and go outward so
we're trying to eliminate the time
vortexes and there's so many of them
there's you said 10 billion uh formal
meetings scheduled in the United States
every single year 90 million
professionals are scheduling these
meetings and there's so many back and
forth that take days you wait a day they
get back to you have to look at your
calendar etc etc so you know companies
like yours at x.ais you just boom you're
ceasing in a virtual assistant a
personal virtual assistant an
intelligent agent that is able to just
super simply and we'll get to the tech
stack but they'll send over a matrix of
calendar options to the other person and
then you'll get to more easily book a
meeting save time it's a huge part of
our Lives it's just again
one of those things for where you and me
could meet Tuesday at four Tuesday at
six Wednesday at 11 they're all equally
good to me what's not cool though is the
back and forth trying to figure it out
because all I have to decide is oh this
is going to be fun this is going to be
awesome I do want to meet with you but
once I've made that decision
I don't want to participate I said
making the decision that's
where I add value figure out one time
over another as long as it's within my
preferences just
figure it out and that is where software
in so many places at this very moment
can take over I said I don't need to
participate in that and there's
certainly some
techno technological challenges some
social challenges that we need to kind
of overcome when we turn a human process
into a software process and that's fine
yeah yeah there's um there's something
really interesting about how you you
know you're starting to describe these
these tasks as though you know I'm the
gatekeeper of making the decision once I
make the decision I want to meet with
you I don't want to do the busy work I
don't want to do the drudgery and that
same thing can be applied to all of
these decisions that okay well I decided
that I want to to eat a specific style
of food okay great go and find me the
best style of food that I selected that
I want to eat in my local area thank you
there's so many of these
if you're
out of ideas
of what to do in life or you're working
your little list of startups to do come
next year
you need to go no further than your
inbox just look at each one of those
emails for where you kinda
think a little because you have to kind
of reply to it that's an opportunity
because that email
shouldn't be in your inbox to begin with
or if in your inbox you have you should
have some agent just taking care of that
you might want to say oh but I need to
inject one input of mine up then just
allow the agent to act on your behalf
with that one input yes good
off you go yes yes
and so then there are ways to design
this Tech stack that give you more
control of the valves of letting the
agent run with your calendar run with
your decisions Etc you can turn off some
of those Valves and gain more control
yourself it's like the access control
keyboard
so I want to talk about the tech stack
behind this technology so so run us run
us through this it's a it seems as
though there's a lot of natural language
processing and generation that happens
here because you uh add Amy to the email
where you want to schedule with Alan and
you say schedule with Alan for the first
week of March uh uh at 200 Broadway and
then maybe you'll give an afternoon
maybe you'll say in the afternoon maybe
you'll say something like that so then
Amy will parse that and figure out okay
he wants the first week of March in the
afternoon
um at 200 Broadway and then Amy will
send me
the generated language of the options so
you'll generate the the the email text
body saying hi Alan I'm Amy and then
you'll give a matrix of time examples
and so teach us about kind of how the
technology works so I think one way to
connect
a backdrop for really
any agent in the not too distant future
is that the agent needs to be able to
understand the request
and given language is not a solved
science there's no such thing as just
writing freely you can certainly Cal out
one corner of the universe try to
understand that to the best at your
ability and sometimes you would even
need to kind of rely on the customer to
just enhance that if you didn't
understand it in full
like having to ask Alexa one more time
or telling Amy that you meant at the 200
Broadway office not the 15 broad office
and if you do understand it then the
next kind of step is some sort of
reasoning engine where if I do
understand you emailing Amy saying that
you're going to be running five minutes
late
that's all good but what do I do with it
as in what sort of actions do I take and
that depends on the type of agent if
five minutes perhaps nothing if 10
minutes perhaps notify Dennis if 30
minutes probably reschedule and whatever
set of scenarios that you can imagine
you need some reasoning engine that
would be the same for any autonomous
agent if the car can see that there's a
pedestrian in the road you need now some
sort of decision framework for where you
should probably stop the car or that
would be a good idea now if you do then
have a reasoning engine that can take a
set of decisions or kind of fully
navigate this universe then the output
will obviously be some sort of
computational outcome you need to kind
of turn that back into language so you
can communicate with your constituents
you know the host the customer multiple
guests and for that you need some sort
of MLG engine for where you can write
back in a language and or design that
you can understand
and that is uh I think kind of the three
primary components now the reasoning
engine should not just be one for where
this is what you
said but it should obviously be a
reasoning engine that
Builds on what I've told you before
which is I don't really like 5 a.m
meetings no I'd rather not meet for
three hours straight I do need a little
bit of breathing room in between my
meetings
when I say the office I mean this
particular office when you send an
invite please send it to this particular
calendar all types of things I would
want to kind of say once but only once
and then there could obviously be
certain constraints that arrive from the
guest which is I'm actually only in
Manhattan next Thursday so I know Dennis
that next week but we're just gonna
collapse that into just Thursday because
that's the only day I'm going to be in
the city so that is I think
three components anybody who does
anything would need to think about now
what typically happens here given the
complexities around
language understanding is that you end
up probably over investing in that end
and that is
perhaps a mistake for where you should
figure out exactly how much you want to
invest in that so you don't starve
your reasoning engine which I think that
is probably where we can invest the most
right now and get the biggest bang for
the buck and you can certainly not
starve the nlg because then you end up
with really just a bag of templates and
that doesn't really do justice to your
agent and I think plenty of people have
seen this kind of very sparse bag of
templates coming straight out of the
engineer on one end very little
reasoning just some basic logic put in
place and then given language is so hard
all hands on deck let's work on that
so I want to give you I want to give the
viewers an example so here I am using
I'm using my phone and here on our phone
as you'll see Okay cool so here's our
message shot with Dennis so I'm going to
jump into the text message and when you
see the text message you see the the
options that pop up that is called an
engram at the top I'm I and we right up
here and when you so those that is a
predictive algorithm for what you would
want to start your sentence with and
every time that you click on one of
those not only are you training the
algorithm every time you click it but
you're saving time that's the most
important thing and so we will get to
voice in a bit I want to get to voice
but I want to go through some examples
you know you talked about the reasoning
engine so that's the processing of the
language that I would give to you in the
conversation
yes that's the geek in me now I think
it's uh please
probably important to separate the
actual ability to understand language
and see that as a separate nlu challenge
when you do understand it
then you need
some ability to reason about what you
just understood as in I have a funny
Danish accent but if I tell you I have
to kind of end this at six o'clock you
now need to figure out what do I do with
this information Dennis said he had to
run up to a meeting at six but what is
your next action you did understand it
but you might actually not know what to
do with it interesting so that's it this
is broken down two very kind of separate
kind of challenges so we we have a
natural language processing then from
the processing we have to understand the
information and understandings like you
just said that I know that it's six but
then the reasoning kicks in which is
okay do we need to speed things up how
do we need to move next can we push it
back 10 minutes whatever we need to do
and so then those are the next options
and that's right now a really tough
place for this sort of reasoning engine
this is difficult to build and figure
out how to best move forward and you're
kind of playing with the different
situations so here's here's a couple
things I want to maybe hit back at you
so
you give these examples of people
sending very weirdly worded messages
because I work a lot at 1 or 2 A.M and I
always say like if I'm meeting with them
that that day I say today because I send
it at 2 A.M and so when they open it
they'll see it as today but some people
will say tomorrow and that will throw
things off so there's these weird quirks
that we have and also there's a
there's a um
you you gave you gave this really good
understanding that you can say that you
you always want to meet at 200 Broadway
you always want to never meet at 5 00
a.m so you can give these sort of a
basic levels of code that then the
algorithm can understand you can add
input to the algorithm so it can better
understand what your preferences are and
so there's this really interesting
interplay then between the amount of
control you have with the scheduling
with the intelligent assistant and also
the amount of that the intelligent
assistant needs to reason and understand
the situation and this adds a very
interesting degree of learning that's
going on with these machine
intelligences
it's
it's a super interesting time right now
for where we've been able to get access
to ever more data and some of the models
that we weren't able to really get to
perform at what we had hoped for perhaps
10 15 years ago are now performing at
a very impressive level and that allows
us to kind of truly train on things and
see systems become way smarter tomorrow
versus yesterday through its sheer use
of the system that is certainly uh
extremely exciting and something that we
are you know not betting the farm on but
building a company on which is that the
more meetings we schedule I think the
smarter we really end up being at
scheduling meetings so whatever version
of Amy that you might have touched in
the past if you touch Amy or Android
tomorrow it's really two different
people or entities yes and this is much
more cost effective too we're making
things cheaper we're making them faster
and better and so you rather than
needing a forty five thousand dollar a
year personal assistant you pay eight
bucks a month to use something like x
dot Ai and here
again
if you want to bucket things there's a
whole set of agents for where it seems
obvious that they might replace
a function that a human might have done
previously but then there's also in the
other bucket a whole host of functions
for where we take something that used to
be a luxury and democratize it so here's
the thing that 10 billion following
meetings being set up in the U.S every
year less than 0.1 percent are being set
up by admin staff I said that idea of
the personal assistant you know because
you've seen it on the Telly but they
don't really exist in real life sure yes
in Manhattan in finance here and there
you spot them but they don't really
exist as in almost all of us
set up our own meetings yeah that's the
norm that's not about replacing
something that used to cost 45k you know
that is about you being punished in such
a sense where you would have to sit at
11 PM in your underwear at home fiddling
with your meetings and now you don't
have to do that and I think those are
two very different things SN
that self-driving car doesn't replace a
chauffeur that I used to have hang
around my apartment no I used to just
drive myself right so in in that regard
I think we need to kind of separate
those two
if that makes any sense yes absolutely
and you gave a really good understanding
there of just the percentage then it's
point zero one percent it's super low
that the actual uh people that have a
personal assistant how many people have
a personal show for how many people have
personal cook personal cleaning staff
those are just luxuries for where I
suddenly know why they exist I can
certainly imagine me having it but I
can't imagine me paying 60k a year to
have some personal chef hang around the
apartment
pouring cereal for me now I'll figure
that out myself yeah but there might be
some Machinery hey you know what for me
to kind of get this uh juice type drink
I'll buy a little machine for that then
I don't have to gonna walk down to the
street and I can
have a slightly automated setting and
tomorrow it'll be a little bit better
the whole kitchen just you get to pick
salad pasta whatever you like and then
boom boom boom boom boom the kitchen is
such an exciting place right now for
what we haven't really seen much change
we've seen a few machines a few machines
enter yeah but they've kind of stayed
the same
they're slightly sexier but they kind of
stay the same you and me should start
adventuring that
I have I have two I have two interesting
questions that I think you'll um so when
first first is do we is it as simple as
just syncing with my Google Calendar and
then it's red yeah and there's my
availabilities
we schedule meetings for a living that's
what we do no more no less the way it
works is that you sign out for now
what's the next Endeavor we'll figure
out soon
we could move that over but we're really
hyper focused on meeting I just want to
make sure that if you pull out your
phone right now look at the events on
your calendar and I didn't put them
there then I got work to do that's
that's my goal in life now you sign up
you connect your calendar so that we
have visibility into it when you're free
when you're busy and so on and so forth
because if you don't then you hired a
blind assistant that wouldn't work and
the way we get access is through basic
Google and or Microsoft authentication
we do not ask for access to your inbox
that means we can't see anything which
you write to anybody about but when you
do want to wake up the agent you simply
CCN the agent as an email address
there's nothing you've installed there's
no plugin no extension or add-on it's
just an email address like you hired
somebody and if you want to hire Tom
Tom doesn't come with an app Tom is just
Tom and you write Tom and tell him hey
Tom I want to do three things for me and
it's the same with Amy and Andrew just
write hey Amy can you get me and Alan
together on 200 Broadway for half an
hour come first week of February and you
click Send now the agent will then read
and understand what did you just ask it
to do
read that back to you so you know that
it is all good and kosher and then
continue by removing you from the
conversation reach out to one or more
participants negotiate either through
some visual uis text language you
clicking onto a website and picking your
time you connect in your calendar
there's multiple ways but that doesn't
really matter what matters is that we
are kind and polite and efficient
towards the guests and that you don't
have to be involved in it and that
typically takes if it's two humans about
1.9 day on average not because it takes
that long to write an email but because
I send it you're working you write
something back I'm off working or
something and that ping pong takes
shorter two days
here though you click Send then you
click archive why because this is not
your job anymore and that I think is a
really important kind of Distinction
here there's plenty of software that
will augment your work make you a little
bit faster a little bit more accurate
but you're still in charge it's still
your jar so if you do some sort of
financial model for your startup for the
year 2020 that's your job and you'll
certainly be using Excel for it but at
no point when you present that to your
board or you say hey me and my pal Excel
have been working on this for the last
three weeks no you did it and this type
of software and there'll be many more of
us it's software you cannot describe the
objective don't get insisted in the task
describe the objective hand it over and
say you do it yeah if there's some sort
of obstacle
let me know I'll help out but I want to
make sure we agree on who owns this and
you do Amy or Andrew and that I find
really interesting and that is certainly
software that kind of excites me that I
can start to begin to describe things in
objectives and not uh little features
yeah they're very easy to use and time
saving this is the kind of stuff that is
a big part of our future now what
happens if I also have x dot Ai and you
have x dot AI then can they go back and
forth so this is uh
what we talk about around the office as
scheduling Nirvana right I've just CC
and Amy asked her to put something on my
calendar for first week of Feb between
you and I you reply back saying oh
awesome I've ceased it in Android my end
he can hash it out with Amy
but if Andrew is saying me
who the hell is she talking to what we
don't do which would be funny haha
perhaps is sending emails back and forth
between ourselves what we do is some
sort of
internal machine language and it turns
into a preference negotiation where we
maximize the happiness on both ends so
we both adhere to your likings and my
likings so in that little Venn diagram
of one or more people we find that kind
of optimal spot for where ah yeah next
Thursday
four o'clock meeting room 9f that's what
we're gonna do so that is where this
particular type of product many similar
products have real massive Network
effects for where the more people using
it the better is for the whole
population yes yes and then do you have
a specific staffers that will train them
the machine learning algorithms to deal
better with the replies that you get so
let's say you get the very obscure
replies from me and then you have to now
try and train Amy to get better that I
wanna oh well I replied saying I want 60
Minutes instead of 30 and I replied
saying that I need a well-lit quiet
space and then Etc so tell us about that
so we have about
70 people right now that does nothing
but data labeling damn and that means
the more data we have
the better Amy and Andrew and the whole
system generally performs so we invest
heavily in that seven zero seven zero
yes doing data labeling that is crazy
data labeling only yeah that's crazy and
that just
if anything sends a signal about the
value of data in this day and age
yeah that's cool so then you are you are
training the algorithms through this
data labeling and then it's better
understanding as the information comes
in how to best reply
um and on that now
you could turn this into a four hour
kind of mini seminar that's the
very kind of part for where you want the
most robust data set possible so that
you can make the highest
or most accurate predictions possible
but that's one part we're also in
somewhat uncharted waters right now for
where the conversational UI
is so so new that we don't have 10 years
of best practices to help best put
together an agent so if you and me kind
of got together this weekend to act
together some app for some funny thing
that we came up with we'll have some
idea of both
who of our friends to call how to put it
together so it looks like an app where
if you open it up you're kind of almost
immediately know how to use it
that's not the case with the
conversational UI
we don't have really Decades of
experience we've had some voice systems
in the past that I'm not so sure fully
carry over to this new conversational UI
Paradigm that we're in right now with
Alexa and the Googles and the katanas
and so on and so forth and that has been
super interesting and we've made a ton
of mistakes but I think we are
slowly starting to figure out exactly
how to best design an application within
that UI framework
awesome segue into the future of voice
so teach us about what your thoughts are
as we enter into this realm of having an
emotional connection with software of
all different sorts that makes our lives
easier
so I certainly think it's important
again to make a distinction between
the agent and the UI where the agent
might live so people might mix these two
together so the conversational UI is
just a UI just like the command line is
a UI or the graphical user interface or
perhaps the mobile UI is a distinct UI
in its own right but the conversational
UI is just another way to interact with
your user and there's plenty of things
that can happen that UI that does not
have to be intelligent or does not have
to be an agent and it could be as simple
as a Citibank sending me a text message
asking me whether I did this transaction
yes or no it only takes two inputs one
for yes two for no and that's that and
it's an awesome use of that isn't it way
better than trying to call me like they
did five years ago so that is a distinct
UI now the reason that we tend to kind
of collapse those stories just that the
agent
has a very good home within the
conversational UI because when you want
to describe objectives describing
objectives is kind of cumbersome in drop
downs and check boxes and radio buttons
but it's very easy in language hey set
something up for some afternoon last
week of January at my office okay
exactly what drop downs and check boxes
did I just describe there but it was
very easy for me to kind of just say out
loud so that's why the agent has a good
home there now the agents that we will
see in this space uh kind of right now
all over the place from Little kind of
toy things that shouldn't even be an
agent or shouldn't even be within the
kind of a conversational UI to more kind
of ambitious settings for me and my 100
propeller head friends haven't worked on
this problem for five years straight and
everything in between right yeah
there's some voices such a big part of
the future to almost to the extent where
we might not even learn typing likely in
the future this is crazy that we're
going to be interacting with these
spatial Computing Technologies and that
I want to just facilitate most of the
things that are drudgery in my life
through these artificial intelligence
assistants
um you we were talking just as we as we
entered in here about this journey of
Entrepreneurship you just mentioned the
five years of hard work with your team
the the you have these peaks of really
excitement you have these lows of like
of of sadness and anxiety Etc there's
really no like I'm good in the like
neutral state of entrepreneur it's like
writing these crazy waves and I'm glad
that you're that you're building this I
want to get a couple quick
um principles on the way out
entrepreneurship's obviously super
important um go and execute always
um okay what's a core driving principle
of your life
be happy
when I get to the end
which sounds sad and it isn't and I sit
and look back with my kids and grandkids
all I really want to be able to say is
that was fun wasn't that fun we had fun
didn't we doesn't matter what car what
apartment
how much money I made did we have fun
yeah that was a good ride and then I can
go to sleep and say it was all worth it
that's my life that's all I'm driving
towards I love it I love it and then how
about we ask you if you could rebuild
civilization how would you design it
so I'm Danish
or as
my American friends call me the
Socialist so immediately you know run
away screaming right now there's plenty
of things that
did not work in that system
which is why I'm over here such as the
celebration of Entrepreneurship and risk
and reward which works extremely well in
the US but the decency totally and
safety that comes along with certainly
what we built back in Scandinavia isn't
as dangerous as some people might want
to make it and
there's there'll be plenty of things
which I will be taking from that version
but I would try to pair it with the uh
Lust For risk reward and the celebration
of Entrepreneurship
and joy of other people's success that
you really see over here and if there's
some sort of amalgamation of those two
things they'll be my version what a
pairing I love it and then last question
is what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world
young people dreaming of a better future
that gets me excited even silly things
or things I actually barely understand
this and why is that important but I can
see somehow it's super important to them
they're kind of
that is something we just shouldn't kill
we should make sure that there's room
for them to uh dream big and dream about
tomorrow and anything which we can do to
support that lean in
very powerful answers Dennis thank you
again so much for coming onto the show
and this is awesome to us I'm really
grateful that we had you we should do
another hour I know I know make a repeat
event we'll do it once a year we will
yeah we will we will we have uh you're
welcome in our studio in San Francisco
anytime I'll let you know when I'm
coming to New York next everyone thank
you so much for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you let us know your thoughts
in the comments below we'll be unpacking
all of the Nuance around these
intelligent agents more as we keep doing
shows and also go and check out x.ai the
links in the bio go and check them out
they have a 14 day free trial give it a
go and remember the more people that are
using this the easier it is for us to
schedule meetings with each other and
lastly is continue supporting great
organizations like Dennis's and ours and
join us links below as well so we can
continue sustaining this and growing it
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your destiny into the world
much love and we'll see you soon
cheers